hi I'm Ryan today I'm going to be
watching the trailer for transcendence
I'm nervous I'm like really nervous I
have a lot of anticipation anxiety for
this trailer like the first trailer got
me really intrigued and this one I I'm
sure I'm gonna get even ten times more
intrigued man I love Johnny Depp I'm
gonna give you guys a little bit of my
joining depth depression it's only funny
if you've seen him in an interview
specifically inside the actors studio
hello I'm johnny depp when i first read
the screenplay for um pirates of the
caribbean halfway through the script i
realized i'm playing a pirate yeah but
everyone's more excited about the fact
that the guy who's done all the
walking's films walking the [ __ ] Nolan I
was thinking to Christopher the guy
who's done all in Nolan's films and
excluding interstellar which looks
compelling nothing like Matthew
McConaughey crying away from a cornfield
first trailer really Jack me up look
like great sci-fi giant app is not being
mr. oh I'm wacky again he's giving a
real like serious performance this time
around hopefully it's not laughable you
know the trying that might insert a
little bit of comedy in there you know
jaidev does it anyway let's get this
trailer on the road you know it's really
not setting the mood for me I got Selena
Gomez a song who says who says you're
not perfect stuck in my [ __ ] head
right now right time to transcend
the path to building super intelligence
the path to building super intelligence
secrets of the universe fundamental
secrets of the universe so if future
movies do they make plants grow really
fast some people to save lives once
online its analytical power will be
greater and the collective intelligence
of every person or in the history of the
world well she's cute who she
to answer right now independence from
technology riff all over the country
rift gonna turn was stopped any attempt
what you call transcendence
we're looking at five weeks before
system shuts down I'm gon keep moving
forward oh my god we can upload his
consciousness that can save him not like
this if we missed anything how do you
know who you did well my god my mind has
been set free Oh Zoe you can't shut him
down
Wally Pfister I don't know the danger
she connects to the internet the first
thing it'll do is copy them and then
there is no taken it down the real will
die whatever it is building an army out
there it's evolution this isn't
devolution was an abomination what Elsa
shutting depp's evolving too fast I
don't understand this is the future
dudes really look so cool
have you fallen out of love with me oh
have you last-minute looks beautiful if
we don't stop it will be beginning of
mankind as we know it whoo I max yes I
max if you haven't seen a film like on
an actual I max screen like the dark
knight Dark Knight Rises mission
impossible ghost protocol tron legacy
hunger games catching fire yeah those
movies were had a lot of the film shot
with IMAX cameras and it is a phenomenal
and I don't know if this is shot with
IMAX cameras but regardless some movies
that just transfer to imax are just 10
times better you ever met someone says I
don't like hi max what the [ __ ] is wrong
with them dan way back to this whoa
looks deep looks at nautic looks
romantic it looks like it's got so many
different elements it looks like a true
cinematic experience you know it's like
that's what I look for and I watch a
[ __ ] movie is to experience stuff you
know feel emotion and [ __ ] whether it be
through adventure sci-fi or you know
romance fantasy whatever the [ __ ] it may
be as long as the emotions felt let's
recount sand from a trailer alone like
everything about it looks moving like
the story looks great the performances
look awesome i love the science fiction
behind it the cinematography obviously
is going to be great because for you
idiots out there who don't know when you
call yourself fans of film this is the
guy who is a DP for a lot of Christopher
Nolan's movies that sounds smarter than
you now because I know a fun fact oh
yeah this one looks like it has it all
and I think like it looks like one of
those songs were people are like I'm not
sure if it's gonna be a big hit but I
think it's gonna be a huge hit because I
think this is going to be a type of film
like grasps on you know it has a little
bit of inception thing to it and giant
debt being drunk with power that might
be fun to watch when I first played a
computer halfway through the script I
realized I didn't come with any porn